Hello, we're David y Maciek,
web application
development experts.
The two of us have designed
this course for Hackademy
about Google App Engine,
the auto-scalable platform
by Google that will allow you
to create scalable applications
for thousands of users
without having to worry
about the infrastructure
of the servers necessary
for its operation.
In this version
we will accompany Paco,
a web developer that works
in the local census office,
step by step while developing
his application.
We will cover all the necessary
basic aspects
to help Paco develop
with Google App Engine,
and we will explain
some good procedures
that are integral
to use this platform.
Grab your tools and help us
develop Paco's application.
HELP US DEVELOP
PACO'S APPLICATION!
This year, the office wants
to make the population
information capturing process
a lot more efficient.
Paco's task
is to create a web tool
that allows people to enter
and register some data.
Initially,
it will be somewhat simple,
for example:
the number of people
that make up the family nucleus
or the educational level
of family members.
The census application
will expect to receive
some 30 million people
in a period of two days.
This means that if traffic
is equally divided
between 6:00 a.m. and 8:00 p.m.,
Paco will have to design
the system in such a way
that it's able to process
at least 298 applications
a second.
But this rarely happens.
The most common scenario
is that users enter
certain hours of the day,
causing peaks,
and the application
will need to attend
to between 1 and 2 thousand
applications a second.
Something like 120 thousand
transactions every minute.
The most important:
the application must be ready
in 30 days.
What technology stack
would you recommend Paco use
to build his application?
What would the most
important points be
to keep in mind
during development?
Let's think for a minute.
If Paco tries
to configure a solution
with traditional architecture,
he would need to:
equip a web server
able to attend to
the 2 thousand applications
per second;
equip a database system
with similar capacities;
equip a cache system
to guarantee
good performance
from the application.
But Paco knows that web servers
are temperamental
and they like to go down
at the worst moment.
That's why he plans
to have at least two servers
working in parallel,
in such a way that,
if one fails,
the other can continue
to function
and the census can develop
without any problems.
Since servers with a memory
of more than 32 GB
are relatively expensive,
Paco decided to use four servers
with 32 GB of memory each one.
At this time,
Paco's necessary function costs
during 2 weeks
to complete configuration tests
are approximately 1,200 dollars.
But he still needs to solve
various problems:
contract a similar configuration
for the database that will store
the information and another
for the cache system,
at the same time
he implements a reliable way
to monitor his servers.
All this keeps adding costs
and a lot of work to the project.
With all of this to do,
it's better to work quickly,
or it's possible the project
won't be ready on time.
Paco will be in charge
of implementing
the application, but,
with only 30 days available,
Will Paco be able to equip
all the infrastructure
the servers need?
App Engine is a platform
for application development,
completely scalable
and managed by Google.
Paco quickly notices that,
with Google App Engine,
he can develop the application
with his favorite language
and he can begin to test it
as soon as
the first prototype is ready,
without having to deal with
any server
configuration aspects.
With App Engine, Paco's
application will automatically scale
the number of requests
from entering traffic
and complete the thousands
of consults per second needed.
In addition, it will help him
to save money
by destroying the requests
when they are no longer needed.
But, what will happen
to the database?
With App Engine,
the application database
will function through
Google Datastore.
Datastore is
a distributed database,
that makes sure
there are multiple copies
of each record.
In addition, the information
will always be available,
even when census
application traffic
grows higher
than initially planned for.
Since Google App Engine
offers free services
to developers, Paco decides
not to wait any longer
and to try it now.
The only thing he has to do
is start developing
his application.
A great way to start
familiarizing yourself
with Google App Engine is
through the official documents.
There you will find
a large amount of information
about how
the platform functions,
as well as the different
services offered.
Don't forget to download
the code that comes
with the lessons
from the GitHub repo.
KEEP PROGRAMMING!